i'm here hanging with former first lady
laura bush who's on the line from texas
so mrs bush your daughter barbara and
her husband ended up moving home to
texas
while everyone was in quarantine just
for a bit so what did you do with the
family back home
she was in graduate school and that her
graduate school had gone virtual
so she was on zoom of course all day but
we were at the ranch
and this was sort of at the very
beginning of the
coven shutdown and so um
so we went for long walks uh that's what
we love to do and then we watched a lot
of
different uh series on television oh
definitely
that's our new entertainment oh
absolutely netflix it was a
wonder during the pandemic um so it
helped us all
um so what's your favorite way to spoil
jenna's kids and what
what does jenna have to say about that
you all got all that hang time
yeah exactly well her favorite thing to
do with them which
i don't know if she's thrilled about but
we
love for them to come in early in the
morning and get in bed with us
i don't know when we're staying together
i don't know if you ever saw those old
photographs of the bushes in bed with
everyone the entire family all their
kids around them
in maine yeah but we've carried on that
tradition
so meal and poppy come get in bed very
early uh before jen and henry are up
and then of course what they want to do
is get our ipads
and work on them so now my ipad my
wallpaper
is a picture of my two cats mila knew
how to do that
another background is a picture of our
dog mila knew how to set it up that way
so it's actually been an advantage for
him to play on my
ipad oh my gosh my children as well i'm
39 but my six-year-old can navigate it
better than i can
it's crazy and i'm like how do you know
this password and she got somehow she
knows it
um but do you have any favorite texas
family traditions
texas family traditions we go to the
texas state fair
oh well that's a given yes do you eat
fried there do you eat like the funnel
cakes
do you go for it no not really but
one year when barbara and jenna were
little and we lived in
dallas and we went to the texas state
fair and jenna was
chosen to be the red pig cheerleader at
the pig races
that was amusing
i am totally bringing that up the next
time you talk
oh that's awesome um but since we're
both texans
i think we have time for a quick game we
are calling lone star love
i'll say something that's truly texan
and we will share if we've ever done it
here we go had a family member who
created their own homemade barbecue
sauce
[Laughter]
no we i haven't had that but my dad's
best friend in midland
owned johnny's barbecue oh the barbecue
joined in midland so
he and spent a lot of time at johnny's
barbecue and he would mainly pick up and
bring it home for us to eat at home oh
that's awesome
i i don't have anybody in my family but
i definitely have a couple friends
um okay so um have you ever told someone
it's pronounced
told someone it's pronounced pecan not
pecan
no but i've always used pecan me too
and everybody yeah i think it's like the
joy any georgia friend or anybody they
say pecan
and i'm like it's pecan it's not tomato
tomato it's pecan
pecan it's pecan um we made it so
um okay so i say this all the time um
have you ever said
all y'all because y'all just isn't
enough i yeah
you probably don't sure all y'all do
okay no i say all y'all
okay i mean i say y'all and i say all
y'all
yeah okay me too i feel okay i feel
cooler
now i thought i was gonna feel less than
when you answered that um
okay saying deep in the heart of texas
in front of the alamo
no i haven't done that but i will the
next time i go to san antonio i know now
it's a challenge to both of us i feel at
this point i've never done that either i
love that that was i love that people my
staff thought that texans might do that
that's my favorite part um okay
you've gone um from texas to texas on
vacation
have you ever done that yes sure of
course yeah
just like i mean growing up you we went
to el paso or we went to san antonio or
we
went to houston or you know you just
would drive from midland to all those
different places
that was your vacation that's so cool we
um didn't no
she was just like have fun in the
backyard in the woods
create your own adventure we didn't do
no you know we went to galveston once
when i was a little kid and i thought
we had hit the lottery yes i thought i
thought it was the most amazing thing
ever
um okay admitted that fort worth is
better than dallas
you might not but i will no i live in
dallas
i know well i live in dallas dallas is
better than fort worth no ma'am
no i'm just um i'm just kidding yep i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever